français jamais encore autant de
personnes ne s'étaient mobilisés pour
dénoncer le racisme toutes les
formations politiques les associations
de défense des droits de l'homme ont
ainsi appelé à ce rassemblement
aujourd'hui à corte pour mettre un terme
à cette vague de violence raciste qui
secoue l'île depuis deux ans maintenant
stéphanie déjà 500 personnes dans
l'amphithéâtre de corte le plus
important rassemblement jamais organisé
contre la xénophobie en corse à
l'origine de la manifestation des
associations antiracistes cette fois
soutenu par des syndicats et surtout des
partis politiques
même les élus nationalistes se sont
aujourd'hui tenues de s'exprimer
clairement sur ce phénomène inquiétant
je veux dire très clairement que l'on ne
peut pas se demander qui ni du peuple
cause ni du nationalisme comme si l'on a
en pensée ou en arrière pensée un
quelconque fond raciste
chacun son tour les participants
prennent la parole il exprime un malaise
et une envie commune de briser le
silence qui entoure le racisme ordinaire
devenu pain quotidien pour la communauté
maghrébine
je suis corse aimante qui s'affairaient
au cospar marocain j'attends que chacun
d'entre nous réagissent vous lui
moi mes professeurs les amis c'est en
chacun de nous qu'il faut qu'on se batte
un rassemblement qui dénote dans un
climat délétère et violence ce matin
encore un agent consulaire marocain a
échappé à un attentat à la voiture
piégée la corse au paroxysme de la haine
raciale
jamais la communauté maghrébine a été si
persécutés une trentaine d'actions
violentes sur les six derniers mois
banques marocaines pâtisseries
orientales plastique et et le pire hier
encore à ajaccio le gérant d'origine
marocaine de cette station service est
abattu de cinq balles en plein jour
comme une ultime provocation de
groupuscules clandestins raciste avant
le rassemblement de corte